[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est l'une des plus grandes réserves
animalières de la planète
vingt mille kilomètres carrés de savane
peuple et des plus beaux animaux
avec philippe nous survolerons les
montagnes du drakensberg
pour guy corps
par contre
au pied de falaises vertigineuses
nous plongerons dans l'eau glacée de la
rivière blade
avec michel laforest pied nous longerons
les berges troubles de lolif entre river
les énormes
énorme reconnaît il arrive comme ça
c'est gros crocodile il faut au moins
cinq mètres à capturer des petits
hippopotames
à basse altitude nous piste auront les
braconniers
chaque jour dans le bush
des rhinocéros sont abattus
on a essayé d'amener la balle mais
centrale a dû traverser l'année malal
part on parle
et puis avec un homme nous suivrons la
formation des futurs ranger sans
qu'elles aient
enfin avec marion et fabrice nous
découvrirons la vie dans un lodge sud
africain
la savane du team bâti fait partie du
grand parc naturel kruger
c'est ici que fabrice et marion gère une
réserve animalière
maud baril signifie conserver
c'est donc symbolique
nous devons tout faire pour préserver ce
dernier bastion de beauté
bastia l'eau
c'est parti
on a plusieurs fermes et si on consolide
les toutes les fermes on a à peu près de
1200 hectares
mais
on a des accords avec nos voisins et on
a l'autorisation de passer chez les uns
chez les autres et donc nous traversons
avec les clients de mode soirée environ
12 mille hectares
d'origine parisienne fabrice a rencontré
marion il y à 21 ans depuis sa vie a
radicalement changé on a juste construit
à toi pourquoi être protégés de la truie
et c'est donc tout c'est en permanence
ouvert on a déjà perdu deux frigidaire
leyen les gagne dès que ce soit fut
complètement hermétique lienne sentent
qu'il ya de la viande à l'intérieur
celui là était légèrement mal fouillé
mais on a perdu deux pôles le frigidaire
précédent elle a carrément fait des
trous avec ses dents elle a fait tomber
l'intégralité du frigidaire et tous et
s'est cassé elle ne porte s'est ouverte
et du coup la hyène a eu un excellent
repas
ce sont les parents de marion qui sur
les berges de cette rivière ont posé il
ya 50 ans la première pierre du lodge
à cette époque le lit de la rivière
étaient couverts de végétation
la bande à débroussailler pour avoir
un mode varie les animaux vont et
viennent à leur guise
on a régulièrement des éléphants qui
viennent dans le lit de la rivière et
qui parce qu'ils sont relativement haut
viennent boire dans la piscine à 90,50
les animaux ne changent pas leur
comportement est d'offrir n'interférons
jamais
leur milieu naturel est resté intact
depuis des générations
comme ici la faune est totalement
sauvage les safaris sont toujours
encadrés par des rangers armés
avant chaque départ ils doivent
récupérer une arme à l'armurerie
en sorte que nos hôtes bénéficie de la
meilleure protection possible escalade
attaques d'amman final
les fusils sont tous de gros calibre
vous devez calculer la distance qui vous
sépare de l'animal vous ne pouvez pas
lui tirer dessus comme bon vous semble
en coin 15 mètres puis 10 puis 5 à 5 m
vous pouvez tirer
les règles sont très strictes
en vingt ans de safari chadrac a utilisé
son arme une seule fois
au cours d'une marche dans la savane je
suis tombé sur une lionne j'ai dû lui
tirer dessus et là dessus
mais je ne pouvais rien faire d'autre
elle était à moins de deux mètres de moi
j'ai juste eu le temps de lever mon
fusil et tiré dans la tête elle était
déjà dans les airs en train de
m'attaquer
chadrac et l'un des rangers ce les plus
expérimentés du domaine de mode ce baril
ce matin il va tenter avec marion et
fabrice de localiser un rhinocéros pour
le safari par emilie
ici comme partout dont le kruger il n'y
a pas de clôture les animaux traverse
les propriétés ils n'appartiennent à
personne
regardez un éléphanteau il n'a pas l'air
d'avoir plus de six mois
il n'y a pas beaucoup de végétation à
manger en cette saison alors ils cassent
les branches s'étire sur les racines
pour apprendre à utiliser sa trompe
pas
depuis trois ans la pression des
braconniers a décuplé
et les plus touchées sont de loin les
rhinocéros pour la valeur de leurs
cornes leur position et donc garder
secrète
à la radio vous ne pouvez pas prononcé
loi rhinocéros alors
on utilise un autre
moment
on essaie de les préserver des
braconniers
cherche donc les traces
sur le point de semble pas plus mal pour
les notables avec
ces employés ça ce sont les traces d'un
rhino
un rhinocéros est passé là il y à
quelques heures
regardez la trace est encore fraîche je
préfère la direction qu'il a prise qui
parle à
chadrac
[Musique]
entame la trappe
ou voyez son pied là un petit doigt ici
l'arrière du pied encore un petit doigt
et enfin le gros orteil
quelques minutes plus tard
il est là bas on va s'approcher
il n'y a pas un rhinocéros
mais deux
à quelques kilomètres de là
ça peut pas ici
shawn heins autres rangers de mode marie
dit fabrice et marion c'est ici qu'il y
a quelques semaines il a découvert la
carcasse d'un rhinocéros
c'est une côte on aurait pu penser qu'il
y aurait plus de traces et les vautours
et yen ont été très efficaces
voilà
voilà tout ce qu'il reste de l'animal
la corne est un peu plus dense
mais c'est la même matière que nos
ongles donc je veux
où nos cheveux
si ce n'est pas utile pour les animaux
comment cela pourrait-il être bénéfique
aux hommes ça n'a pas de sens
et pourtant la corne de rhinocéros se
vendent actuellement sur le marché
asiatique au prix de l'or
dans le kruger la nuit tombe en quelques
minutes
le second lui les périodes de pleine
lune sont les plus dangereuses car c'est
là qu'il ya le plus de braconnage les
braconniers peuvent se déplacer sans
lumière et ils doivent pouvoir s'y
arrêter
ce soir un mario et fabrice vont dîner
dans la maison de famille d'accueil
depuis que je suis toute petite je viens
ici
c'est il ya très longtemps
pour aller à l'école je devais aller
plus loin car il n'y en a pas dans la
savane poche
oui c'est mon frère il était avec un
rhino
c'est en sa mémoire et celle de mon père
que nous avons appelée c'est andrea le
camp eggers
aujourd'hui la maison de famille a été
transformé en lob pour accueillir les
touristes
tout autour la savane s'étend à perte de
quelques dizaines de kilomètres plus au
sud
vite un autre français
[Musique]
philippe berjaud est arrivé en afrique
du sud il ya trois ans ce matin elle est
classe est ouverte
je devinais qu'elle était ouverte parce
qu'il faisait nuit je suis réveillé à
ses taux en fait j'étais debout à 5h15
ancien préfet du maire
philippe a construit son avion un murphy
de ses propres mains
[Musique]
voirie
mais en vain
on va commencer par si on venait à
l'odomètre arscott j'habite
paris s'engage
en direction de l'ouest les plaines
défilent sur plus de 200 km non pas
rigueur
à côté
en tant que les réserves soient pas doit
être de rigueur quand
tu peu avant 10h au centre bell où les
bras
à l'est les dragons monde hinse les
montagnes du dragon
une barrière naturelle qui culmine à
près de 2000 mètres d'altitude
en plein coeur de la cour ch
philippe ne se lasse pas de ses paysages
sous ses ailes rien n'a changé depuis
des millénaires
[Musique]
salle de tous les avions ici tu vois ça
c'est le plus le plus délicat à atterrir
tous les ans en juin
la résidence dans laquelle philips est
installé accueille un show aérien
[Musique]
moi je
sais quel modèle
c'est un rebel rebel
jusqu'en afrique du sud avec un an et
demi c'était une sacrée expérience
à vol d'oiseau deux kilomètres à peine
séparent la piste de la maison de
phillip
[Musique]
il ya la vue sur sur sur ces montagnes
le drakensberg en face on devine
derrière le
l'entrée du blyde river canyon
c'est pour profiter de cet espace que
philippe a convoyé son avion depuis la
france
mon fils on est tous les deux dans
l'avion en vol on s'est pris avec la des
pros là on aperçoit les côtes
mauritaniennes
le désert namibien
22 jours d' aventure une traversée de
toute l'afrique
[Musique]
depuis peu philippe a lui aussi décidé
de rejoindre la lutte anti braconnage
logiquement c'est dans les airs qu'il y
participera
alors on hisse le drapeau français tous
les jours et aujourd'hui un peu de vent
donc il va bien flotter parce qu en fait
j'aime la france et je suis fier d'être
français donc nous la fiche on en grand
nous sommes une petite enclave des
derniers irréductibles gaulois en
afrique du sud
vivre au coeur de la savane michel
laforest on rêvait aussi depuis
longtemps
on a acheté cette réserve en 2000 après
trois ans de recherche parce qu'on
voulait vraiment trouver un endroit qui
n'avaient pas été exploités
et la plainte viable
2 3 4 5 6
alors être tous à l'intérieur
et donc maintenant ça fait une quinzaine
d'années connaître ici on a tout
construit on a amené
l'électricité en souterrain aucun câbles
apparents
son lodge est le seul de la région à
proposer des safaris guidées en langue
française
alors quand on explique par exemple le
système spongieux du cerveau de la
girafe qui absorbe le trop plein de sens
quand elle boit pendant deux minutes
sinon elle fait un avc c'est plus facile
à comprendre en français qu'en anglais
quand on n'est pas à 100% bilingue
aujourd'hui nos payal et une réserve de
300 hectares peuples et de toutes sortes
d'animaux
il n'est pas du tout agressif comme vous
pouvez le constater il est même plutôt
reconnaissance et bien mon grand vin tu
vas je vais te rends démarrer la voiture
faut que tu laisses endroit
assez bonne
michel vite ici toute l'année on arrive
dans mon bureau au milieu de la brousse
alors c'est un petit bureau dans une
cabane en bois et ça permet quand même
d'être lié au monde
quinze ans de 15 ans de safari en
famille
ce souvenir là je pense que c'est le
meilleur de tous mais safari j'étais
assis sur le siège du pisteur c'est mon
fils oscar qui conduisait le véhicule et
il y avait des traces fraîches de lyon
juste devant il ya tous les gosses qui
était derrière et moi je disais à masi
les images les traces sont rafraîchies
doit pas être loin et un moment il ne
bouge pas et les lions et sur le nom sur
sa gauche et le lion passe devant moi au
niveau du genou et c'est une dame qui
était derrière qui a pris la photo je
n'ai absolument pas bouger il m'a
regardé dans les yeux une seconde je
pouvais lui toucher la tête et là là
j'ai senti le gros frisson et plus beau
il est parti il a continué son chemin et
ça a été un très très bon très bon un
très bon moment mai 2011
tous les trois mois le lodge accueille
deux jeunes stagiaires français
donc là l'objectif aujourd'hui après
avoir été dans la grande savane ouverte
mardi
céder au contraire d'abord de voir la
forêt de mau panne ce que vous pouvez
faire c'est vous rentrer par la porte de
palabres roi
aujourd'hui c'est jean baptiste qui va
guider les clients
un jeune couple en lune de miel
longez la rumeur s'est passé
des éléphants les eaux
on va se laisser guider par les par les
animaux qu'on va trouver
sarah
le parc kruger est grand comme trois
fois la corse là où le gouffre comment
plus de 20 me kilomètres carrés de
savane arborée
dans l'hémisphère sud
c'est en hiver que l'eau se raréfie
l'accès aux points d'eau est très
hiérarchisé
éléphants devant
[Musique]
abbasse et leur dû ils vont aller voir
c'est génial
[Musique]
depuis peu le kruger est ouvert sur le
mozambique pour permettre la migration
des animaux
et si on aime bien parce qu'il ya un
petit point de vue en haut des rochers
là où on a une superbe vue sont arrivés
à
la vue sur le kruger le mozambique
devant nous derrière les montagnes de
l'est bongo
l'accès au mozambique a permis de
doubler la superficie
c'est ici que jean baptiste a décidé de
s'installer j'ai tout lâché là en france
c'est pour commencer une nouvelle vie
ici ça fait sur niveau de vie
m'intéresse pas je m'en fous de gagner
de l'argent pas si je peux tous les
jours me réveillais aller dans le bush
ça me suffira sur le chemin du retour
annoncé d'ebola marchait sur la route
avec le soleil de 6
sera ce jeudi
vous avez la taille des patines
a
lyon solitaire
en possession de son territoire
manificat
c'est pour lui
poursuite avec les lions ben c'est bon
jb a rempli sa mission les jeunes mariés
sont combles
bois
aux anneaux
le lendemain matin
clés à la jeune stagiaire de novaïa a
organisé une rencontre insolite
où ils sont si mignons
nous sommes des professionnels
et notre devoir c'est de veiller à votre
sécurité
ces deux guépards son nez sur la
propriété ils sont sauvages se nourrit
seuls
ils tolèrent cependant la présence
humaine sous certaines conditions mais
il n'y aucun cas vous pouvez vous
approchez pieds carrés c'est comme ça
il adore
vous voyez c'est ça qu'il aime vous
grattez intime d'arrêt c'est assez
normal il accepte
[Applaudissements]
sébastien est le premier à se lancer
c'est un gros chat c'est ok stand up ok
maintenant l'avez vous ai laissé libre
elle venait par derrière passé pour tous
les jours par derrière jamais par devant
sinon il peut vous donner un coup de
griffe
cléac'h ouvre la voie pour aurore qui
n'est pas du tout convaincu
donc l'oreille tu peux ici
[Rires]
ouais c'est moi toi mais en même temps
tu te dis s'il n'avait pas le sujet
[Musique]
à l'autre extrémité du parc kruger ou à
partir de maintenant
on regarde
michel guide un safari sur la rivière
olyphant
il ya un crocodile qui traverse
il est énorme
énorme crocodile
il arrive comme ça c'est gros crocodile
il faut au moins cinq mètres à capturer
des petits hippopotames
la rive ironiquement n'est jamais à sec
et sur les berges l'adverbe verte ce qui
permet aux animaux d'avoir du feuillage
et de l'air toute l'année donc en hiver
quand c'est très très sec évidemment la
rivière olyphant va attirer énormément
d'animaux
[Musique]
et suisse au fil de l'eau
les animaux se laisse approcher au plus
près
[Musique]
je fais toute l'année ce que les autres
rêvent de faire quelques jours donc je
suis un homme heureux
un équilibre pour lequel anna a elle
aussi décidé de se battre
elle retrouve ses amis sud-africaine
shannon et myriam au centre hippique de
ocz pride
passionnée d'équitation anne a quitté
son île natale de la réunion il ya cinq
ans elle développe aujourd'hui des
safaris à la carte en voiture ou à
cheval
les animaux donc du coup ils ont entendu
des bruits du pas du cheval et ils ont
l'habitude et ils ne voient pas en tant
que forme humaine donc moins menaçants
donc on peut approcher moment très près
les girafes les zèbres et aucun sou tant
que cheval est habitué parce que parfois
ça peut être impressionnant 6 pour les
chevaux qu'avoir une girafe et cee en
fait qu'ils paniquent à comparer aux
animaux sauvages
cet après midi anna va explorer un site
qu'elle souhaiterait ajouter à son
programme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai je suis me réveille le matin
je lis chaque jardin je portais figure
presque tous les soirs à la maison comme
en nba si paradis sauvage
[Applaudissements]
à nos vies dans une réserve au beau
milieu du bush
la chiche
d'avis
il veut où il vit dans le toit il a
déménagé quand il était tout petit en
mettez dans le placard et après donc la
déménager tout en haut du plafond
qu'est ce que c'est 1 c'est un petit
gars nago son nom ségala à gomme orly
et en fait c'était un petit primate un
tout petit singe c'est un des plus
petits que tu peux trouver sur la
planète
voilà ça c'est la gratuit sur la tête sa
mère
à 26 ans annonce est parfaitement
intégrée à la vie sud africaine ce week
end elle retrouve un groupe d'amis pour
une expédition dans les montagnes
j'adore cet endroit correia les des
centaines de fois sommes enlacés
on dort pas toujours là bas parce que ça
demande une grosse organisation faut
détendre des couvertures
en moins d'une heure de piste
le changement de climat et de végétation
et spectaculaire
on arrive au niveau de la forêt
tropicale qui est très humide à chaque
ronde en fait ce qui se passe et les
nuages restent coincés au niveau des
montagnes et d'entrée remplissent verve
et qu'on peut débuter
le marié scop est un parc naturel
protégé
le prix d'entrée dépend du nombre de
tentes
bon combien de temps tu une à
l'extérieur
où se tendent pour vous tous
monsieur salies ne fera pas recette
aujourd'hui en
montagne
à pala fans pour retrouve dans la savane
comme dans le parc ouvert mais il peut y
avoir encore des léopards des coudes ou
toutes les antilopes de montagne
le parc doit sa renommée à sa rivière
la blyde river
au fil des siècles a creusé dans la
montagne un canyon de plusieurs
kilomètres
[Musique]
on
on est happé nature en avoir que faire
ce qu'on veut
c'est agréable on est nul part ça nous a
pris environ deux heures pour venir
jusqu'ici et là on se retrouve dans un
monde imaginaire squeeze peut pas lutter
pour protéger ce paradis anna n'a pas
hésité à s'engager
[Musique]
ce sont quelques snare dans quelques
pièges quelques collet qu'on a trouvées
dans des réserves sur lesquels on
travaille en fait là ce serait par
exemple sur rhinocéros ou de la girafe
ou encore tout est gros animaux comme
les buffles
la dernière réserve sur laquelle on a
travaillé n'avait pas des kids anti
braconnage on est arrivés sur le terrain
on a trouvé 200 pièges
depuis son arrivée en afrique du sud
anna collabore avec pro traque une
société privée spécialisée dans les
opérations antibraconnage
ça fait partie de ma vie de tous les
jours j'entends winehouse
et j'entendais compte tous les jours
l'année dernière en afrique du sud plus
de 1200 rhinocéros ont été tués par les
braconniers
aucune réserve et épargner
parce qu'à l'aller on verra ce qui se
passe
chez johnatan beretta les hautes
clôtures électrifiées et la coupe
systématique des cornes à titre
préventif ne suffisent pas à protéger
les rhinocéros
serino a été blessé deux fois par arme à
feu 3
et une autre fois avec une saga
ses jours sont comptés ils l'ont touché
au visage
heureusement l'alerté a été
immédiatement donnée
mettez un élément dans les côtés et on
l'a repéré et on en est donc je faisais
partie en fait de l'équipe à terre et en
fait on qu'on fasse une corde dans les
pattes de rhinau pour l'aider à tomber
sur le côté
lui mais un bandeau sur les yeux et
après on a commencé à le traiter qu'est
ce qui t'a fait j'avais une balle qui
était rentré en fait sous l'oeil colle
quand c'est rendu compte avec détecteur
de métal
la balle était assez partie de l'autre
la mâchoire
depuis cette attaque manquée et malgré
leur corne coupée trois rhinocéros ont
été tués
6 heures du matin quand deux formations
de la société pro traque
30 recrues ont cinq semaines pour
devenir des rangers ce professionnel
l'avant match et apparemment cela tu en
es tu pour préserver ses droits
le braconnage c'est une histoire sans
fin on ne gagne pas beaucoup d'argent
c'est vraiment par passion compter
les instructeurs du camp sont d'anciens
militaires
ici chaque candidat paye sa formation
environ 1000 euros et si il abandonne il
perd son argent
et une arrivée à ton coéquipier il a
abandonné quand ça
je sais plus très bien il ya
trois-quatre jours mais sans blessés
ce
prêt pour l'épreuve de tir bon
hop
les épreuves de tir sont éliminatoires
a pris depuis plusieurs jours vous avez
coupé
n'y aura pas de deuxième chance pas se
désole sergent vous échouez vous rendra
à la maison c'est compris
premier
leur formation terminée les rangers sont
envoyés sur le terrain
le parfum et qu'il devait donc et en
fonction de la superficie la réserve on
envoie plusieurs ayez une équipe et
après il reste pendant ses shows sur la
rivière
pour survivre dans le bush
c'est l'eau potable vous pouvez boire
mais
il faut savoir être autonome
c'est vraiment potable risen oui la
raison pour laquelle je pouvais avoir
confiance en cette hausse est qu'elle
est c'est grâce au sable et surtout à 7
secondes et
les hommes doivent aussi apprendre à
faire face à des braconniers armées
ennemies en vue à 12 heures là tu vu
préparez vous avancez
enfin de 3,4 à genoux avec je suis à
genoux je tire
[Applaudissements]
armes de guerre
balles réelles
les entraînements sont des préparations
militaires
j'aime le danger et j'aime les poussées
d'adrénaline
ça va être une bonne année
je connais mes points forts et aussi mes
points faibles
je sais à quoi je m'engage et je suis
très enthousiaste
les deux tiers de cette promotion ont
réussi leurs épreuves ils seront bientôt
déployés dans le bush
en mode varient fabrice et marion
viennent d'apprendre une mauvaise
nouvelle
les ont trouvés la carcasse marino sans
cornes
ensuite il nous donne les coordonnées
gps
et c'est signé mark shaw et c'est une
scène de crime donc on va l'appeler on
va essayer d'aller voir si on regarde le
plan
mode soirée est ici exactement ici le
camp et ça se trouve au nord juste à la
frontière avec le cruiser pas
bonjour marc comment allez vous désolé
on a un peu de route
c'est bon
la carcasse était là depuis combien de
temps à peu près 2 3 jours une gestion
en patrouille à pied et nous avons vu
les vutuka tournoyait hong ap les
rangers du kruger ils nous ont dit
qu'ils avaient attrapé deux gars ce
samedi c'est ce que j'ai lu et
maintenant vous allez faire des
prélèvements d'adn
exactement ça pourrait nous permettre
d'établir un lien
nous arrivons sur la scène du crime
les rangers du parc couleurs ont
sécurisé le périmètre pour qu'aucune
trace ne soit détruite
voilà les traces
là c'est la mienne
encore une autre 23e
les traces de trois braconniers ont été
identifiés
un peu plus loin la carcasse du
rhinocéros tués est en cours d'autopsié
fric russo coordonne l'opération
ils ont pris les deux cornes les ans
sûrement utilisé une hache ou une
machette et les prélever ça n'a pas été
complet ou six
les braconniers ont réussi à s'enfuir
avec leur butin
l' enquête commence
il faut retrouver lamballe pour établir
un lien avec l'armé du crime
on a besoin d'un détecteur de métaux
carla massacre était trop importante et
ça nous donne une indication de
l'endroit où chercher la balle
la balle mais sans succès elle a dû
traverser l'animal de part en part
fric et ses assistants doivent
maintenant prélevé plusieurs
échantillons de la carcasse
maintenant nous allons envoyer ces
prélèvements au laboratoire de génétique
de l'université vétérinaire de pretoria
ils ont ensuite établir un profil de cet
adn il résultat sera incorporé dans une
valve de donneur
cet adn permettra aux policiers de
progresser dans leur enquête elle sera
identique à celle d'un homicide
d'un producteur de lost
c'est ici au quartier général du parc
kruger que toutes les opérations
antibraconnage sont déclenchés
auto ocz ancien officier des forces
spéciales et le patron des rangers
sommes assiégés des cadres que ténue par
neuf nous avons dix à douze groupe de
braconniers reprend l'activité
quotidiennement dans les parcs
pour les combattre les rangers sont
équipés comme des commandos
fusil d'assaut lunettes à vision
nocturne et gps radio et pitt médicale
d'urgence
il s'agit de protéger et d'équiper nos
hommes pour qu'ils soient le plus
efficaces possible
qu'un soldat bien équipé et motivée sera
plus redoutable sur le terrain''
le centre de commandement coordonnent
tous les services liés à l'anti
braconnage
voici le commandant en chef de la police
il est assisté par un cas de terre est
capté
en théorie des peines de prison sont de
plus en plus jour mais peu de
braconniers sont traduits en justice
alors sur le terrain les règles
d'engagement se sont durcies
vous savez je n'ai pas les chiffres en
tête mais je peux vous dire qu'il ya eu
effectivement je n'aime pas en parler
non pas les schistes et nous avons
neutralisé des pas connu certains
sérieusement et venait enfin certains
n'ont pas su
malheureusement
c'est donc non officiellement que près
de 150 braconniers ont été tués l'année
dernière
mais malgré les risques la pression ne
se relâche pas car le prix de la
corderie l'eau ne cesse d'augmenter
en asie un kilo de corne de rhino vos
cinquante cinq mille euros presque deux
fois plus qu'un kilo d'or est une corne
peut peser jusqu'à ce qu'ils en
allant voir les hélicoptères
les conséquences sont dramatiques
l'année dernière le parc kruger a perdu
827 rhinocéros
je vous présentais à kokomo
yako pilotes l'un des quatre
hélicoptères de surveillance du parc
ils effectuent plus de 40 missions par
mois
en moins de douze heures il peut
intégrer l'impératif
pour surprendre les braconniers a
découvert les hélicoptères de
surveillance sont les seuls à être
autorisées à voler à très basse altitude
la finition c'est sur les lieux où il ya
une telle qu on la croirait votre aztex
on dépose de limiter confirme la zone
pour mettre la pression je connais sa
part me ranger ses anciens de faire leur
travail sur le terrain
300 rogers armés sont en permanence
déployés dans le bush
et pourtant
2 à 3 rhino qui sont tués chaque jour
regardez une carte place de rhinau là
on la trouvait deux jours après qu'il
l'ait puis
juste en face de nous
on y voir les côtes
si le massacre continue à ce rythme
dans moins de dix ans il n'y aura plus
aucun rhinocéros en afrique
pour participer à cette lutte contre les
braconniers
philippe a rejoint depuis peu un groupe
de pilotes bénévoles qui effectuent les
vols de surveillance
ce matin il fait un vol d'essai pour
leur prouver qu'il est opérationnel
c'est un pilote sud africain il
supervise le test
qu'elle est la meilleure zone a survolé
un jour
c'est la région qui est patrouillée par
les crues lahlou les classes et rebbie
et le temps dati
[Musique]
se trouvent les
ici par exemple c'est la région de
salaire
je connais très bien
et là
au ballet rieden reconnaît tous les
shows de notation et c'est là que l'on
se rend très rapidement juste pour faire
une opération de surveillance
sur survolent chaque set
les vols se font toujours à deux un
pilote et un observateur
on ne mélange pas de problème non
la contribution de filles est précieuse
car son avion est parfaitement adapté
aux vols de surveillance
ouais c'est un très bon appareil rouler
lentement et en plus
on peut voler à 65 ans sans problème
est attendu côté
et puis emplois vers 2011
aux animaux menacés
songy relocalise
en
26 minutes de vol
philippe et ya qu on fait le même
travail de comptage qu'une patrouille
durant toute une journée
cela permet aux rangers sous sol de
patrouille et efficacement autour d'eux
merci beaucoup
c'était un vol on en a pris plein la vue
philippe a passé l'examen il est
officiellement admis au sein de
l'escadrille anti braconnage
au sol les unités de ranger ce travaille
étroitement avec les pilotes
pendant 48 heures nous allons
accompagner leurs patrouilles dans le
secteur du team bâti
dans ce camp si rangers se relaient en
permanence
c'est un vieil
manière occasionnelle dans la masse yeux
aujourd'hui avec le braconnage ont le
cul pont permanent l'un des points
chauds de loud zone histoire les rides
frédéric eolen entament aujourd'hui leur
rotation
parce que le camp est totalement isolé
dans le bush les rangers sont dû
construire une barrière d'enceinte
électrifié
défense approche de la barrière et puis
on entend
après on sort on les fait déguerpir
au sol les rangers sont à armes égales
avec les braconniers
il emploie les mêmes ruses les mêmes
techniques
avec cette technique si des gens neutres
mais ils ne pourront pas savoir vocation
d'être un snob d'animaux
à la saison sèche les points d'eau sont
des zones particulièrement sensible
ce calibre à cause il utilise ses
endroits préférés
on voit du boire sur datta khel france 8
il est suivi des pins est telle que
pour nous montrer comment les
braconniers procède aux laines suis une
trace toute fraîche
laurine olitec à quelques centaines de
mètres du point d'eau
à cette distance
l'animal est totalement vulnérable face
à un braconnier armée
ce soir frédéric eolen doivent
participer à un vaste déploiement
nocturne
on a perdu un rhino récemment et avec
cette pleine lune enfin ce qui va se
passer quelque chose ce soit dans les
prochains jours
sur plus de 10 km par binôme les rangers
se sont positionnés le long de la piste
leur mission est de voir sans être vu
si un animal s'approche un lion pour un
développement par exemple à ota ne faut
pas bouger si
on est bienveillant nous ferons kamal
mais on doit se respecter mutuellement
aullène et frédéric s'installe pour la
nuit
tout autour dans l'immensité du bush les
rangers ce ne sont pas les seuls à la
vie
une lionne suis patiemment un troupeau
de buffles
échasses seul dans l'espoir 19e
[Musique]
juste en bordure du parc hameau payen
chez michel la forêt elles sont allés
boire il se reposer il allait repartir
je pense qu'on arrive au bon moment
c'est l'heure du ravitaillement joli
groupe de nous
jean baptiste jean baptiste pour michel
ou cléa pour me sauver
oui il faudrait couper la pompe ça y est
les points d'eau débordent il est plein
voilà donc une arrivée de nous donc là
ici ils ont un comportement tout à fait
étonnant parce que ils savent que on
vient pour leur apporter à manger et
qu'on les a jamais pour chasser ni
blessé et donc voilà je comprends menée
pratiquement au milieu d'eux presque les
toucher
chez michel c'est un peu l'arche de noé
[Applaudissements]
là en l'occurrence si on n'était pas
d'eau ici si on n'était pas de fourrage
et bien ces animaux irait migrer vers la
rivière aux licences à une douzaine de
kilomètres mais il peut y avoir des
clôtures rentre il peut y avoir des
obstacles et donc ils peuvent plus le
faire comme il le faisait autrefois donc
à nous de compenser en fait je mets
simplement je ramais simplement ce qu'on
a enlevé
un moyen comme dans le parc kruger les
incursions de braconniers sont de plus
en plus fréquentes qui est en train de
damer les pistes la piste principale et
les pistes extérieures de manière à ce
que l'équipe anti braconnage de nuit
puissent voir des traces fraîches
éventuellement ou de braconniers ou
d'animaux
sa raclée à
l'élu quelque chose de particulier
d'accord mais pas de problème sur la
clôture pas de tout va bien et vous
l'avez testé s'il ya du courant tout va
bien
malgré la clôture électrifiée michel a
récemment eu une très mauvaise surprise
voilà en fait quand j'ai pister ces
braconniers je me suis réfugiée derrière
cet arbre puisque le braconnier qui
étaient ici même est parti en courant et
a commencé à tirer donc je me suis caché
en fait derrière l'arbre
voilà j'étais ici et donc j'ai attendu
qui tire tout son chargeur
étant donné que c'était de nuit il
pouvait pas me voir et tirer un peu dans
tous les sens et après donc j'ai pu me
mettre en position et à ce moment là
j'ai pu tirer à droite à gauche au
dessus pour le faire partir et l'équipe
anti braconnage des trois gardes qui
travaillent avec nous l'ont intercepté
un peu plus loin
aujourd'hui mechelle embauché trois
gardes privés
paper guns and dash 8 deux shoots
white box chaque mois les gars
s'entraînent au tir avec des pistolets à
air comprimé
la sûreté est enlevée on peut tirer mais
qu'attention eut déchargé l'un des gars
des nouveaux utilisent les demain
et on regarde de mire est en train de
tuer à sept balles dans le chargeur
les braconniers vont de moins en moins
venir nous visiter et évidemment le
problème se déplace ailleurs où il faut
que les autres fassent la même chose
mais on fait notre police nous mêmes
mais michel n'est pas venu dans le
kruger pour faire la police
ce qui lui plaît plus que tout c'est de
partager sa passion de l'afrique aussi
une tour d'observation qu'on a construit
avec mon fils oscar pour avoir une vue
absolument imprenable sur tout le parc
kruger les montagnes du drakensberg et
les réserves privées et on peut voir à
100 kilomètres à la ronde c'est un
endroit assez magique
certains voient dans cette forme là bas
spice qui serait en fait l'incarnation
des lions blancs un signe particulier
puisque les lions blancs sont des
divinités ici pour les peuples champ de
gan de la région
jean baptiste etc les armes rejoignent
michel pour un moment privilégié
[Musique]
un verre au coucher du soleil
juste au dessus de la savane africaine
[Musique]